- [Narrator] This is no ordinary rabbit.
This is the New England cottontail-
a species that's been pushed
to the limits of its survival.
(gentle piano music)
Nearly identical to its
much more common cousin,
the Eastern cottontail,
the elusive New England
cottontail is found
only in a few isolated
pockets of its former habitat
that once ran from Maine to New York City.
These rabbits have acute
eyesight and hearing.
When they sense danger, they
will typically freeze in place,
relying on their gray-brown
fur to camouflage them.
But when they need to run,
their powerful hunches allow
them to reach top speeds
of 18 miles per hour.
But, unfortunately, their
speed can't save them
from invasive species
and a loss of habitat.
The New England
cottontail's very existence
now hangs in the balance.
This is a New England cottontail rabbit.
(playful music)